what came first Jackass or the offer to
do stunts on Saturday Night Live jackass
came first and right as we were getting
ready to go make the pilot I got the
offer from Saturday Night Live and I was
going to get 5 minutes on the show to do
like a stunt or a prank every week and
for a guy who is waiting tables and
suddenly I got this pilot I'm about to
shoot and then Saturday Night Live wants
me to do something
and it was a lot cuz it's like
everything could fail but I just God I'm
just going to bet on myself and my
friends I would have been lucky to be on
SNL but I wouldn't have any control you
know right I just bet on myself and it
could have been a big failure but it
succeeded yeah it's it's really
interesting I think that a lot of people
would have no idea that Saturday Night
Live offered that to you